i think for me it's about you know being
a member of parliament about public
service and therefore when you see our
country facing different challenges and
you see and you need leadership to step
up to the plate i think as members of
parliament we are all amongst equals
with different unique skill sets and
therefore when an opportunity comes to
serve your country at the next level you
have to step up to the plate and first i
have to say the campaign which i
launched is not a a slick campaign where
thousands of pounds have been
spent or where you've had it's been in
the planning for months or years for me
it was about the a time has come when
you've got to step up and step forward
to serve our country at the next level
with the values that drive you and with
the vision that you have for our great
country and for me it was about well
look at somebody who came to gillingham
in 1984 did not speak a single word of
english and it was about hard work
determination perseverance and
self-belief and you've applied that
every day
in life and as a member of parliament
and before that as a young lawyer
fighting for justice and therefore i
think now it's about stepping up and
giving parliamentary colleagues an
opportunity to look at the skills that
you have that we could work together to
help make our great country even greater
as we work forward
now the last message you put out on
twitter said that you featured a new
statesman as one of them one to watch
but some people that we've spoken to
haven't even heard of you why is that
well i think the the reality on that
vanessa is this it's um it's part of the
campaign which i put forward
aspirational conservatism it's about
fresh ideas and it's about fresh people
and and with that it comes it's about as
a member of parliament you stand up and
you work day in day out for your
constituency and you have creative ideas
with regards to policy areas on mental
health animal welfare whether it's
submissions on foreign policy defense
and security review you get on and get
the job done and you're absolutely right
there'll be people out there who may
have not heard of me because the system
i want to bring about it's a merits
based system you know it's about having
the brightest and the best people at the
top of our uh country making the
decisions for our great country and in
these difficult challenging times you
want the brightest and the best serving
in government at every level and you
know some people may not have heard of
me i accept that but it's not down to me
with regards to what level i've served
in government over the many many years
that have been down to the prime
minister of the day but for me it was 12
years every day you want to step up and
serve whether it's private members bills
on mental health new ideas whether it's
to do with transport safety new ideas in
your name as a member of parliament
working with stakeholders and whether
it's with regards to defense foreign
policy security working with some of our
or one of our best former national
security advisers coming up with ideas
on how we can keep our country safe as
we move forward so yes there'll be
people out there who may not have heard
about about me because i may not have
served in government at senior levels
before and that's not because i would
have not wanted to that comes to the
prime minister of the day but for me if
i were to be you know if i
had the opportunity to serve our great
country as its next prime minister it
would be about a merits based system
having the brightest and the best people
and there are amazing people within the
conservative party you know with talent
across the board and you would want to
ensure that they are coming to
come together as we move forward in
delivering for our country
uh mr chisti you've thrown some
brilliant words at me but let's just
talk about how things that translates
into practical terms so you said in your
campaign that it for you it's about and
you've mentioned some of that there as
well as about aspirational conservatism
fresh ideas and a fresh start taking our
country forward
what does that mean in practice how do
you achieve that well i think the the
question i would say for national night
it's the the
way to achieve that for example from my
own background it's the values that you
have but it's also about the skills you
know that you had you give our future
generations you know our great country
is a resilient country it's a
resourceful country uh if there is
creativity there and for the future the
next five ten to fifteen years we have
to look at the jobs and that will be in
uh it encoding in artificial
intelligence in cyber security to ensure
that our education system you know is
well equipped to ensure that our future
generation get the skills that they need
because if it wasn't for the amazing
teachers i had back in 1984 when i came
in not speaking a word of english i
would not
go off to university to be dear lawyer
and then serve my uh country and a
constituency as a member of problems at
31. so it's about a skills based system
which we urgent need to address and with
that what we have to do is ensure that
we create a system where individuals you
know who day in day out they work hard
they're persevered they're determined
they want a government that's back on
their side and that's with regards to
lower taxes so for me when you ask me
what would i do of course i can't give
you detailed policy i've not seen you
know what the the figures are but the
aspiration is for lower taxation and
with that what i would say there people
in our great country who are doing a
number of different jobs you know to to
get by is to be able to give them tax
incentives and support them as they move
forward in these challenging times